Priyanka Chopra Jonas it is a busy time
for her she produces and stars in the
new drama the skies pink and she's also
writing her first book called unfinished
a collection of personal essays that
comes out in 2020 and now Priyanka is
revealing to us the inspiration behind
her new chapter the first thing I did
when I first signed the contract and I
was a guy I'm gonna get started on this
and I wrote about 20 pages because once
I started writing it just sort of flowed
and it truly did start from a pen and a
paper we've teamed up with Priyanka and
pilot pen to celebrate Priyanka spello
over achievers for the fourth year in a
row pilot pen plans to give $100,000 to
people going above and beyond to make a
difference in their community as part of
their g2 overachievers grant we're
becoming so desensitized to everything
that's happening in the world that we
need to remember that there is goodness
in it and this grant shows you that
we're living in the digital world today
everyone types on their phones my
creativity is directly linked with me
writing with my hand
[Music]